look into the camera and on my  eight-year-old why he can't see this  movie well you can see this movie what  do you not listen to this man ever why  does the world love Deadpool so dark  he's the guy that occupies the space in  this cinematic universe that almost no  one else can occupy you know the DC  Universe is a direct relationship to his  audience that's just lazy writing he's  emotional lot smarter than I look he's a  little immature at times he says the  things that we might be thinking but  never say I didn't say why did I love  Ryan Reynolds no job eyes lovely wife  Blake Lively who of course stopped for a  selfie with her hubby the New York  premiere brought out the entire cast who  had a blast working without hilarious  Canadian I can't do this alone  he is the Magic Man when it comes to  Deadpool he's got the formula nice suit  Stanley he called me to be a part of  this thing because he knows we know  comedy tell me they got that in slow  motion